ça c'est tous des mots que vous
connaissez pas parce que aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on paye on paye le
laisser-aller et le laxisme des
majorités aider des oppositions fagots
des oppositions d'hier d'hier et
d'avant-hier voilà aujourd'hui le
résultat de ce convoi a besoin sont
séduits laxisme vous êtes tous
comptables autour de cette table de ce
qui se passe à bord de ce qui est ici si
vous voulez vous êtes plus ou non la
portée et je les portais durant durant
ce mandat je n'ai pas entendu les élus
de la majorité se prononcer sur les
propositions que l'on apporté pendant
pendant six ans et madame vigneault
aujourd'hui il faut sortir vraiment de
cet angélisme
on n'attrape pas les délinquants avec le
simple maintenant attendez donc on a
déballé d'éléments vraiment avec défile
à lyon ou encore des pistes et vous avez
aujourd'hui solutions trend ou olivier
matéo je vous écouterai simple je vous
ai vraiment écouté dans votre prise de
parole je crois qu'on va essayer de
rester dans un débat est donc nous c'est
recruter former et arméno polysémie
combien est-ce que monsieur regarder le
monde et un doublement au sein de la
projet et un doublement de la police
municipale pour porter à 100 nos
policiers municipaux 7 déploiement ou en
a une cinquantaine tu as exactement
c'est aussi de déployer la
vidéoprotection et c'est de revoir c'est
de revoir les missions de notre police
municipale
aujourd'hui pour qu'on soit vraiment
dans le maintien de la tranquillité
publique et laisser la place à la police
nationale de pouvoir lutter contre la
criminalité et si vous voulez un chiffre
presque nous aussi on l'a fait chiffrer
on est entre 2 millions et 2 millions et
demi d'euros par an par an la parole à
mme à claire arnaud de me disais tout à
l'heure quelle est la nôtre l'art moment
je suis à merci de me redonner la parole
je suis vraiment attristé en fait que
ces événements est dramatique servent de
prétextes prétexte politicien je suis
désolé de le dire à développer ces
mesures là et je pense que vous pouvez
tout à fait moi je vous reconnais le
droit de développer la nécessité de
l'armement de la police municipale mais
s'il vous plaît ne prenait pas prétexte
de ces événements là parce que là on est
face à du grand banditisme et je suis
désolé quand vous dites que armée la
police municipale ça va régler les
conflits de guerres de drogue c'est faux
c'est faux là on est sûr c'est le préfet
qui s'occupe de ça c'est le rôle de
l'état c'est le rôle de l'état et je
vais terminer sur autre chose parce que
la sécurité c'est pas que ça
je suis désolée la sécurité c'est pas
que l'armement de la police municipale
la sécurité
toute une politique est là où je vais
être d'accord avec vous c'est que la
sûreté est un droit c'est un droit
constitutionnel est un droit
constitutionnel depuis 1789
auparavant c'était assuré qu'à une élite
aristocrates ou bourgeoise et c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui a
fait de ce droit un droit pour tous et
toutes
donc on est aussi très attaché à la
sécurité on a aussi un programme sur la
sécurité qui se base notamment sur des
mesures sur des mesures de renforcement
de demander le renforcement de la police
nationale ça c'est un malfrat toussaint
selon le sun ou danser d'admettre que je
termine parce que je vous ai laissé le
débat d'entre vous mais on a aussi
d'autres mesures et moi je voudrais
aussi avancé d'autres mesures puisque on
a aussi un programme sur ce point là on
le veut notamment le retour des
correspondants muc un service qui est
essentiel à la vie des quartiers et qui
était essentielle à la sécurité la nuit
dans le centre qui a été supprimée par
la municipalité précédente
on veut dans le quartier de planoise
remettre de l'humain à remettre des
liens il ya plutôt un ensemble
d'incivilité nous vous parlais justement
qui sont dans les immeubles hlm et nous
on propose notamment le retour des
concierges qui ont été supprimés on va
on va laisser la parole ensemble si les
concentrations l'accord 10